I want to be proud when I walk into a  room that means I have to embrace who I  am as a gay woman it means I have to  embrace who I am as a two-spirit person  even if we couldn't say  lgbtqia  settler Society has sort of teaches us  that we're never really enough you know  and I think it's important to try to  battle those thoughts and those feelings  that come up  trees a lot of the the teachings that  I'm receiving even now  reflect on self-acceptance and that  everybody has their unique and important  space in the circle and without  everybody's voice that Circle suffers  actually I challenge myself to be more  and more vulnerable with the things that  I face in my life and struggles because  on the other side of that is a young  person who needs to hear that you are  important and your struggles make you  great and your passion and your dreams  make you powerful and those combined you  are unstoppable